we've got a voicemail number it's two
one nine two david p here is a voicemail
about my pronunciation let's take a
listen David I'm a linguist and I like
your show but I've noticed you use a
liquid you every time you say the word
new you say new you say we have a new
thing to share with you you've got a
liquid you in your pronunciation and I
just find it a little annoying as a
linguist because I don't think you need
to use that liquid you yeah so part of
my confusion here is at the beginning of
the voicemail the guy didn't have a
British accent but by the end of the
voicemail he did so I don't know if it
me saying new rather than new sounds
weird to him but I've looked it up in
the dictionary both new and new are
except accepted pronunciations in
American English of the word spelled and
II W and I you know listen in the end
English is my second language and I
can't really I'm sort of you can't
criticize anything I say because after
all I grew up speaking Spanish until I
was five and then then learn English so
you know I think you speak English
pretty well thank you do you think this
guy's trolling though or is he running
linguist I yeah very very how long have
you been waiting for that one whole show
yeah that pat has had that but did you
really plan that earlier today yeah Wow
down my notes we've got to end the show
on that now very very clever and it's
you can you could tell Pat's eyes lit up
because he had that one written down man
that was uh sometimes I planned them a
couple days ahead of time but then I
cancel it because I know it's gonna be
so obvious that it was staged but you
actually did pretty well with that one
all about timing every is important the
guy is certainly cunning alright we'll
talk to you on the bonus show